ASSEMBLY MEMBER RACE NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ABDALA. BARRICADE HIM. BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRIAN
BURKE CALDERON RIO CERVANTES
CHEN CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY BLACKY LEE
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA NGUYEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CROOKS SILVA
RAMOS WHAT IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH. STONE
TEAM BALLOT ERRORS THE APPROVED
LAW VOEPEL WALDRON LORD WEBER
WICKS. WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS SAY QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM
YES SIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD THE
MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL
. WE PRAY TO ALMIGHTY GOD AND
ETERNAL GOD. EVER PRESENT TO ALL
OUR UNDERTAKINGS AND ALL OUR
NEEDS. TOUCH EVERY ASPECT OF OUR
LIVES WITH YOUR HOLINESS. MAY
YOUR DIVINE WISDOM DIRECT ALL OF
OUR DELIBERATIONS AND BE
REVEALED AND ALL THE PROCEEDINGS
OF THIS CHAMBER. ALLOW US TO
PROMOTE HAPPINESS AN INCREASE IN
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE. A SENSE
OF COMPASSION FOR OTHERS AND
USEFUL KNOWLEDGE SO THAT THE
BLESSINGS OF SO MANY IN THE
STATE. MAY BE EXTENDED TO ALL I
MEAN. THANK YOU MA'AM YES SIR
YES OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISPRONOUNCING WEEK OF SESSION.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY
GEMMA SACRAMENTO TUESDAY
DECEMBER SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE PURSUANT TO THE PROVISIONS
OF JOINT RULE FOR DONNA FONG IS
IN THE JOURNAL FOR THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
REGULAR SESSIONS PRINT WHILE THE
ASSEMBLY WAS AN INNER CITY
RECESSED MISTER RAY S. MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS. AT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS.
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE. MOVING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
MEMBERS. MS REYES
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
THERE QUE HAN GIPSON IS ARIAN
THREE OF US AND LUCKY TO SPEAK
ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY EIGHT I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
STRIKE. THE FOLLOWING VETOED
ITEMS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
FROM THE FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. ITEM
THIRTY NINE AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY EIGHT THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE GIVEN A
ONE DAY NOTICE TO REMOVE BILLS
FROM THE INACTIVE FILE. ITEM
EIGHT FORTY EIGHT SB THREE NINE
SIX DOLLY. AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES AND ITEM
EIGHT TWELVE AB EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW. I MOVE TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL TO TAKE
UP HIS AJ ARE TWENTY TWO WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO COMMITTEE OR FILE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ADOPTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT REQUEST
IS GRANTED. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. GOVERNOR'S VETOES FILE
ITEMS FIFTEEN AND THIRTY NINE
HAVE BEEN DISPENSED WITH. ALL
OTHER ITEMS SHALL BE CONTINUED.
A RECONSIDERATION ITEMS ON
RECONSIDERATION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SECOND READING
CORPORATE SO MIDDLE TWELVE
TWELVE. ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. FILE ITEMS FIFTY FOUR THROUGH
FIFTY SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS. THERE'S THAT REFERENCE
THE FILE. THIS IS AJ ARE TWENTY
TWO THE CORPORATION. ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL RELATIVE
TO THE SELECT COMMITTEE TO
INVESTIGATE THE JANUARY SIXTH
ATTACK ON THE UNITED STATES
CAPITOL. MR GABRIEL YOU MAY OPEN
. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AJ ARE
TWENTY TWO WHICH CONDEMNS THE
VIOLENT INSURRECTION THAT
OCCURRED AT THE UNITED STATES
CAPITOL ON JANUARY SIXTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I MUST CONFESS
MISTER SPEAKER THAT EVEN WITH
THE DISTANCE OF TIME AND
GEOGRAPHY. IT STILL FEELS
DIFFICULT TO FIND THE RIGHT
WORDS TO FULLY CONTEXTUALIZE
THIS UGLY AND UNPRECEDENTED TAX
ON AMERICAN DEMOCRACY. FOR MANY
OF US JANUARY SIX CONJURES UP
GROTESQUE IMAGES SEARED INTO OUR
NATIONAL MEMORY. A VIOLENT MOBS
STORMING THE CAPITAL. CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS AND BODY PAIN AND
FIRST SWINGING FROM THE WALLS OF
THE SENATE CHAMBER.
INSURRECTIONIST WITH CONFEDERATE
FLAGS IN CAMP AUSCHWITZ T.
SHIRTS HUNTING FOR MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS AND THEIR PERSONAL
OFFICES. EVEN THOUGH IT'S
DIFFICULT IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT
WE PAUSE AND HER REFLECT ON THAT
HORRIFIC DAY. FIRST AND FOREMOST
TO RECOGNIZE THE BRAVERY AND
SACRIFICE OF THOSE WHO WERE
INJURED AND KILLED PROTECTING
UNITED STATES CAPITOL. THE
INSURRECTION RESULTED IN
PHYSICAL HARM TO OVER A HUNDRED
AND FORTY MEMBERS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND MULTIPLE
DEATHS. INCLUDING UNITED STATES
CAPITOL POLICE OFFICER BRIAN
SICKENING WHO IS BEING BY RIDERS
AND DIED OF A STROKE THE
FOLLOWING DAY. AS WELL AS
OFFICERS HOWARD LEAVING GOOD.
GUNTHER HAS SHE TO. PILE THE
FREITAG AND GEOFFREY SMITH WHO
STOOD GUARD THAT DAY AND WHO
TRAGICALLY TOOK THEIR OWN LIVES
IN THE DAYS AND WEEKS THAT
FOLLOWED. IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
THAT WERECALL JANUARY SIX TO
PRESERVE THE HISTORICAL RECORD.
TO BE HONEST ABOUT WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED. SHOCKINGLY SOME ARE
ALREADY TRYING TO REWRITE
HISTORY TO WHITEWASH AND EXCUSE
THOSE WHO ATTEMPTED TO SUBVERT
OUR DEMOCRACY. SO LET US STATE
CLEARLY AND UNEQUIVOCALLY. THE
JANUARY SIX RIDERS WEREN'T SOME
INNOCENT GROUP OF TOURISTS
SEEKING TO PEACEFULLY EXERCISE
THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
THEY WERE A GROUP OF VIOLENT
TRUMP SUPPORTERS SEEKING TO
UNDERMINE OUR DEMOCRACY AND
OVERTURN THE WILL OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. THEY WERE
INCITED TO VIOLENCE BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AND THEY SOUGHT
TO DISRUPT THE PEACEFUL TRANSFER
OF POWER. THAT HAS BEEN THE
HALLMARK OF AMERICAN DEMOCRACY
SINCE THE FOUNDING OF OUR
REPUBLIC. PUT SIMPLY JANUARY SEX
WAS AN ATTEMPTED CO. THAT'S WHY
THE WORK OF THE BIPARTISAN
SELECT COMMITTEE IS SO IMPORTANT
TO PROVIDE A FULL ACCOUNTING
ABOUT THE FACTS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT DAY AND TO
ENSURE MAXIMUM ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THOSE WHO ATTACKED OUR
GOVERNMENT. H. A R. TWENTY TWO
IS ALSO A REMINDER OF THE
FRAGILITY OF OUR DEMOCRACY. AND
THE TREMENDOUS AND WORK IN FRONT
OF US IF WE WANT OUR KIDS TO
LIVE IN A TRULY DEMOCRATIC
SOCIETY. EACH OF US IRRESPECTIVE
OF PARTY HAS AN OBLIGATION NOT
ONLY TO SPEAK OUT. BUT TO WORK
TO ADVANCE VOTING RIGHTS AND TO
AFFIRMATIVELY STRENGTH IN OUR
DEMOCRACY. FOR MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU CONSIDER THE WORDS OF
KARL ROVE. VENERATED BY YOUR
PARTY AND FRANKLY DESPISED BY
MANY IN MINE. WHO WROTE LAST
WEEK ON THE ANNIVERSARY OF THE
INSURRECTION. THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY HAS A DUTY TO CONDEMN THE
RIOT AND THOSE WHO REFUSE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. THERE COULD BE
NO SOFT PEDDLING WHAT HAPPENED
AND NO ABSOLUTION FOR THOSE WHO
PLANT ENCOURAGED AND AIDED THE
ATTEMPT TO OVERTHROW OUR
DEMOCRACY. LOVE OF COUNTRY
DEMANDS NOTHING LESS. I HOPE
THAT EVERYONE IN THIS CHAMBER
WILL JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING H. A
R. TWENTY TWO. IN HONORING THOSE
WHO WERE INJURED AND KILLED
DEFENDING THE CAPITAL. IN
SUPPORTING THE WORK OF THE
BIPARTISAN SELECT COMMITTEE. AND
CONDEMNING ALL FORMS OF
POLITICAL VIOLENCE AND ATTACKS
ON AMERICAN DEMOCRACY. THE OATH
THAT WE ALL SWORE TO THE UNITED
STATES CONSTITUTION. AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DEMANDS NOTHING LESS
. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL MS GARCIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF G. R. TWENTY TWO.
THIS RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES THE
VIOLENCE THAT OCCURRED JUST ONE
YEAR AGO AT OUR CALIFORNIA AND
OUR NATION'S CAPITAL. IF THEY WE
ALL WATCH IN FEAR FOR THE LIVES
OF OUR CONGRESSIONAL
REPRESENTATIVES THE STAFF THAT
WORK THERE IN THE BRAVE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO WERE. THERE TO DEFEND
. THE ACTIONS TAKEN ON JANUARY
SIXTH WORK SIX FOUR THREATS FOR
THE MARKET SEE. AND NOT JUST
ANOTHER NORMAL TOURISTS VISIT.
AS SOME HAVE DESCRIBED IT. THE
REALITY S THAT OUR DEMOCRACY
HAS BEEN UNDER ATTACK WHILE
BEFORE JANUARY SIXTH BUT THIS IS
MADE THAT THREAT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY ARE PRIMED TO THE
WORLD AND MAGNIFIED OR NEED TO
FIGHT FOR THE MARKERS THE WITH
ARDOR. I RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS
A MARKER C. HAS AND ALWAYS WORK
FOR EVERYONE AND IT'S A WORK IN
PROGRESS. LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND OTHER MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES HAVE ORGANIZED FOR
DECADES. TO ENSURE WE LIVE UP TO
THE WORDS IN OUR FLAG SALUTE. OF
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL. THE
WORDS THAT WE JUST AT THE
BEGINNING A TWO DAY SESSION.
HOWEVER THE SYSTEMIC FORCES IN
THE SAME FORCES BEHIND THE
JANUARY SIX INSURRECTION ALWAYS
FOUGHT HARD TO PREVENT THOSE
WORDS FROM BEING TRULY
IMPLEMENTED. LIBERTY AND JUSTICE
FOR ALL. THE GENEROUSLY
CONSTRUCTION IS NO DIFFERENT
THAN THIS DECADES OLD FIGHT.
IMAGES OF THOSE INDIVIDUAL
STORMING THE CAPITOL AND
ATTEMPTING TO DESTROY IT MAKING
SURE THAT WE MUST CONTINUE THIS
FIGHT. WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE AN AMERICA THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYONE ALLOWS EVERYONE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROCESS
EQUALLY SPECIALLY AT THE BALLOT
BOX WHICH IS WHY WE NEED TO
ENSURE WE STRENGTHEN OUR VOTING
RIGHTS ACTS ACROSS THE NATION.
I'M PROUD THAT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE BEEN LEADING
THE WAY. IN ENSURING THAT
REMOVED ALL BARRIERS TO VOTING.
BUT THIS THING IS NOT SURE
ACROSS THE NATION. THE WORLD IS
WATCHING. WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
STAND DOWN AND WE DO STAND DOWN
THAT ONLY FORTY FURTHER THE SAN
FRANCISCO MUNITY IS ON THE FRONT
LINE AND THAT'S TOO MUCH AT
STAKE. IT IS LIKE MINE WELL THE
PEOPLE FIGHTING FOR THEIR
AMERICAN DREAM IN SPITE OF A
SYSTEM THAT HAS. A THAT IS
STACKED AGAINST THEM. BECAUSE
THEY LOVE THIS COUNTRY AND FULLY
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN BE A
DEMOCRACY WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO HAVE NEVER STOPPED WORKING
DURING THIS TIME THAT MAKE SIGN
OUR MASS CLEANING OUR HOSPITALS.
BAGAN ARE GROCERIES BUT ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY ENDING UP IN
THE HOSPITAL WITH COVE AND DYING. IT'S CONGRESS INVESTIGATE
THOROUGHLY THE GENERATORS
ATTACK. TO HELP PROTECT OUR
DEMOCRACY FROM THE SUMMER TECH
IN THE FUTURE. AND THAT WE PASS
STRONG VOTING LEGISLATION IN
CONGRESS IMMEDIATELY I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST- I FELT.
AND I THINK MY COLLEAGUE FOR
MAKING THIS BOARD. THANK YOU
MISS GARCIA. MISS WALDRON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY SIXTH WAS A
DARK DAY IN AMERICAN HISTORY WE
CAN ALL AGREE ON THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO BREACH THE
CAPITAL MUST BE HELD TO ACCOUNT
FOR THEIR ACTIONS TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT OF THE LAW NO ONE
SUPPORTS RIOTERS. IN PROSECUTING
THE RIOTERS WE MUST SEND AN
UNEQUIVOCAL MESSAGE. THEIR
BEHAVIOR WAS UNACCEPTABLE AND
THE VIOLENCE THAT OCCURRED THAT
THEY MUST NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN. SO
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE NATIONAL GUARD
WHO RESPONDED THAT DAY AND PUT
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE TO
RESTORE ORDER AND PROTECT THE
CAPITAL AND ITS OCCUPANTS WE SAY
THANK YOU. WHILE THE EVENTS OF
JANUARY SIXTH WERE HORRIFIC.
THEY COULD HAVE BEEN
IMMEASURABLY WORSE WITHOUT THE
BRAVE ACTIONS OF OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS. MANY QUESTIONS
REMAIN SURROUNDING THAT DAY ONE
THING IS CERTAIN AMERICA WAS AND
STILL IS A NATION DIVIDED. WHAT
OUR COUNTRY NEEDS NOW IS UNITY.
AND I FRANKLY FEEL WE NEED A LOT
MORE LOVE. KINDNESS AND RESPECT
. THIS IS THE TIME FOR
PARTISANSHIP OF FINGER POINTING
IT'S ATIME FOR SOLEMN
REFLECTION ON THE EVENTS OF THE
DAY THE HEROISM OF THE FIRST
RESPONDERS AND THE STEPS WE CAN
TAKE TO ENSURE IT NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN AND UNIFY OUR COUNTRY ONCE
AND FOR ALL. SO I URGE A NO VOTE
ON THIS RESOLUTION. MR BERMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY FOR AUTHORING
THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN- THE ACTIONS
OF TWO DIFFERENT GROUPS. THAT
LED TO JANUARY SIX ONE IS THE
ACTIONS OF THE WRITERS WHICH
WERE CRIMINAL- AND IN AN ATTEMPT
TO. PHYSICALLY TAKE OVER OUR
CAPITAL. WHERE THEY ASSAULTED
LAW ENFORCEMENT THIS ALL TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH. THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON BATONS. WITH FIRE
IF WITH FIRE EXTINGUISHERS. AND
EVEN WITH THE AMERICAN FLAG THAT
WE ALL PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO NOT
TEN MINUTES AGO. THEY BROKE INTO
THE CAPITAL. THEY DEFECATED. IN
THE CAPITAL THEY URINATED IN THE
CAPITAL- AND EVERY ONE OF THOSE
LIKE LIKE THE MINORITY LEADER
SAID EVERYONE OF THOSE PEOPLE.
COMMITTED CRIMINAL ACTS AND
SHOULD BE HELD TO ACCOUNT FOR
THE ACTS OF A COMMITTED. BUT
THEY'RE ALSO THE ACTIONS OF THE
PEOPLE WHO SPREAD IT THE LIES
THAT LED TO THE RIGHT ON JANUARY
SIXTH. AND IT'S NOT ONLY
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO'S BEEN
SPREADING LIES ABOUT OUR
DEMOCRACY. BUT IT'S BEEN OTHER
OF POLITICAL OPERATIVES IT MAY
BE USED THEIR AND THEIR SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS TO TRY TO
CONVINCE AMERICANS THAT THE
ELECTION IT WASN'T APPROPRIATE
THAT THE ELECTION WASN'T
ACCURATE THAT THE ELECTION
WASN'T SAFE. AND THESE ARE LIES
AND THESE ARE LIES THAT LEAD TO
ACTIONS THAT WE SAW ON JANUARY
SIXTH BUT IT'S ALSO THE PEOPLE
THAT STAY QUIET. IN THE FACE OF
THOSE LINES. IT'S A PEOPLE WHO
WON'T STEP UP AND ADMIT AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE PRESIDENT BIDEN
IS THE DO WITH DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IT'S THE PEOPLE WHO WILL
CONTINUE TO PROPOSE. LIES ABOUT
OUR ELECTIONS AND THE ACCURACY
OF OUR ELECTIONS- THAT OCCURRED
LAST NOVEMBER I TWO NOVEMBERS
AGO EXCUSE ME. IT IS THOSE
PEOPLE WHO STAY QUIET IN THE
FACE OF THESE LINES. THAT ARE
JUST AS COMPLICIT AS THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE LINING IT'S THOSE PEOPLE
WHO REFUSED TO STAND UP. MAYBE
THE LEADERS IN THEIR OWN PARTY.
TO SAY KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
WRONG WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
UNPATRIOTIC WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
UNAMERICAN AND YOUR VOTING THE
FABRIC OF OUR DEMOCRACY BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT IS HAPPENING IN OUR
DEMOCRACY IS AT A CLIFF EDGE
RIGHT NOW. ANYBODY WHO DOESN'T
THINK SO IS KIDDING THEMSELVES.
YOUR ATTEMPTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
FOR POLITICIANS TOOK OVER TED TO
UNDO THE WILL OF THE ELECTORATE
TO PUT THEIR CHOSEN POLITICIAN
IN POWER. YOU ATTEMPTS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY USING THIS THESE
LINES. AND USING THE UNCERTAINTY
THAT THOSE LIES AND CREATED TO
TRY TO UNDERMINE OUR VOTING
RIGHTS IN AMERICA. AND WE ALL
MUST SPEAK OUT AGAINST THIS
DEMOCRAT DEMOCRAT REPUBLICAN NO
PARTY PREFERENCE INDEPENDENT WE
ALL MUST SPEAK OUT TO TRY TO
SAVE OUR DEMOCRACY. BECAUSE I
WOULD ARGUE THAT OUR DEMOCRACY
IS A GREATER THREAT NOW THAN
IT'S BEEN IN MY LIFE. AND I
THINK IN MOST OF THE LIVES OF
THE PEOPLE IN THIS. IN THIS
ROOM. SO I HOPE PEOPLE TAKE THIS
AS SERIOUSLY AS THEY NEED TO
THIS IS A PARTISAN. THIS IS
AMERICAN. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
OUR DEMOCRACY. AND I HOPE WE CAN
ALL AGREE THAT OUR DEMOCRACY
SHOULD BE STRONGER THAN ONE
PERSON'S CRAVE IN. ATTEMPTS TO
GAIN POWER. THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
OUR DEMOCRACY IS TO STOP THAT
FROM HAPPENING. SO I HOPE
EVERYBODY REALLY THINK STRONGLY
ABOUT THE WORDS OF THIS
RESOLUTION. I HOPE EVERYONE
REALLY THINKS ARE STRONGLY ABOUT
THE ACTIONS NOT ONLY ON JANUARY
SIXTH BUT THAT LED TO JANUARY
SIXTH. AND THE ACTIONS THAT HAVE
CONTINUED SINCE JANUARY SIXTH.
TO TRY TO UNDERMINE AMERICA'S
DEMOCRACY THAT WE ALL HOLD HOLD
SO DEAR- I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF A
J. R. TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR BERMAN. MISTER
BENNETT. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU THE CORNERSTONE OF OUR
DEMOCRACY IS THE PEACEFUL
TRANSFER OF POWER. AND A DIRECT
THREAT ON THE PEACEFUL TRANSFER
OF POWER NEEDS TO BE. CHALLENGED
AND PEOPLE NEED TO STAND UP IF
YOU WANT TO BE PART OF OUR
DEMOCRACY YOU HAVE BOTH THE
RESPONSIBILITY AND THE PRIVILEGE
TO FIGHT FOR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS BENNET. THANK YOU
MEMBERS SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION MR GABRIEL
YOU MAY CLOSE ON THE RESOLUTION. MR THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM. LO ANGELES
COUNTY AND MENLO PARK INVENTOR
FOR THEIR VALLEY ELOQUENT WORDS
IN SUPPORT OF THE RESOLUTION. A
FEW WEEKS AGO- I WAS BACK IN
MARCH AND YOU SEE WITH THE
NUMBER MEMBERS OF THIS BODY- WE
WERE FORTUNATE TO BE BACK THERE
FOR THE SIGNING OF A BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL. WE HAD A
NUMBER OF MEETINGS WITH THE VICE
PRESIDENT I'D STATES WITH.
MEMBERS OF OUR CALIFORNIA
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION. AND
WHAT STRUCK ME SO POWERFULLY
ABOUT ALL OF THOSE MEETINGS AS
YOU KNOW WE BEGAN WITH WITH CHIT
CHAT ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THE NEED TO BRING DOLLARS BACK
TO CALIFORNIA. IT'S TRANSITION
FROM CONVERSATIONS ABOUT POLICY.
TO CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF OUR DEMOCRACY. AND HOW
WORRIED AND CONCERNED AND
FRIGHTENED. PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON
DC ARE ABOUT THE VERY CONTINUED
FUNCTIONING OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
AND I WOULD SAY I AGREE WITH A
LOT OF WHAT THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER SAID TODAY ABOUT THE NEED
TO LOOK FOR ABOUT THE NEED TO
COME TOGETHER ABOUT THE NEED TO
HEAL. I AGREE VERY STRONGLY WITH
THAT BUT I'M STRUGGLING TO
SQUARE THAT. WITH VOTING NO ON
THIS RESOLUTION AND I WILL TELL
YOU SPEAKING FOR MYSELF WHAT
CONCERNS ME AND WHAT I THINK
CONCERNS MANY MEMBERS. OF MY
PARTY AND MANY MEMBERS OF THIS
STATE AND THIS COUNTRY SO MUCH
ABOUT THE EVENTS OF JANUARY SIX
. BEYOND THE APPALLING IMAGES.
BEYOND IT THINGS THAT WE THOUGHT
WE WOULD NEVER WITNESS IN THIS
COUNTRY BEYOND THE PHYSICAL
ATTACKS ON THE UNITED STATES
CAPITOL MEMBERS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE EFFORTS TO
UNDERMINE THE WILL OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. EVEN SCARIER
THAN ALL IN THAT EVEN MORE
UNSETTLING THAN ALL OF THAT. IS
THEREFUSAL OF SO MANY NATIONAL
POLITICAL FIGURES TO BE HONEST
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED. TO BE
HONEST ABOUT WHAT TRANSPIRED TO
BE WILLING TO CALL THIS
INSURRECTION. THIS VIOLENT
ATTEMPT TO SUBVERT DEMOCRACY
WHAT IT IS AND IN FACT OF THOSE
WILLING TO DO IT ARE SO
NOTICEABLE. RIGHT SO NOTICEABLE
WHEN PEOPLE LIKE LIZ CHENEY AND
KARL ROVE PEOPLE WHO MANY OF THE
DEMOCRATS IN THIS ROOM HAVE
OPPOSED AT EVERY STAGE OF THEIR
POLITICAL CAREER IT'S SO NOTICE
WHEN THEY'RE WILLING TO GET UP
AND SPEAK TRUTH TO POWER. AND BE
HONEST ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT THAT
THE WORK WE HAVE TO DO TO HEAL
OUR DEMOCRACY TO COME TOGETHER
TO BUILD A BETTER FUTURE FOR OUR
CHILDREN. THAT REQUIRES US TO BE
HONEST ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED. AND
TO REFLECT ON HOW WE CAN DO
BETTER. AND I BELIEVE VERY VERY
STRONGLY THAT IT'S INCUMBENT
UPON ALL OF US TO WORK TO BUILD
A STRONGER DEMOCRACY. AND THAT
BEGINS BY ACKNOWLEDGING. THE
EVENTS OF JANUARY SIX. BY
HONORING THE BRAVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO DIED.
AND WHO WERE INJURED PROTECTING
THE CAPITAL THAT DAY. BY
SUPPORTING THE WORK OF THE
JANUARY SIX COMMITTEE. WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
AJ ARE TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU MR
GABRIEL MYSTERY WHERE WOULD YOU
LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE H. A R.
YES MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS THIS
WILL BE FOR CO AUTHORS ON AJ ARE
TWENTY TWO THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. ON THE
RESOLUTION. WELL. CLOSER ROLE
THERE ARE FIFTY CO AUTHORS ADDED
THIS IS AJ ARE WE WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS FOLKS
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY THREE
NO TO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS OF THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO LIFT THE QUORUM
CALL AT THIS TIME. REMAINING
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
PLEASE GIVE A RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION YOUR COLLEAGUES.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE ANY
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
AT THIS TIME. WE ARE
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS
WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF OF THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME.
MANY MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS. PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
WERE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON THE GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MISTER NAZARIAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF
VALENTINA OR JANA AT ALTA. ON
DECEMBER TWENTY THIRD VALENTINO
WAS THE INNOCENT VICTIM OF A
STRAY BULLET. WHILE CHRISTMAS
SHOPPING AT BURLINGTON COAT
FACTORY. FONTINA WAS ONLY
FOURTEEN YEARS OLD HE SAID IN
THOSE SHORT FOURTEEN YEARS SHE
MADE A PROFOUND IMPRESSION ON
THOSE WHO KNEW HER. SHE WAS
DESCRIBED BY HER FAMILY AS A
SPECIAL GIRL WITH A BEAUTIFUL
SMILE AND A NOBLE HEART. AS AN
IMMIGRANT FROM SHEILA. WITH
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY SHE
PROVED HERSELF CAPABLE OF
ANYTHING SHE EXCELLED AT AND SHE
EXCELLED IN HER HIGH SCHOOL.
HIGH TECH L. A. AND LAKE BALBOA
. DESPITE HER LANGUAGE BARRIER.
HI TECH HIGH SCHOOL COLLEAGUES
IS WHERE I'VE HELD OF THREE-
HIGH SCHOOL CHESS TOURNAMENTS
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC OF BECAUSE
IT WAS A PROGRAM THAT I STARTED
WHEN I FIRST TOOK OFFICE AND I
JUST WONDER IF GIVEN HERS
INTEREST IN SCIENCE IF MAYBE SHE
WOULD HAVE BEEN. JOINING THE
CHESS CLUB THIS YEAR AND MAYBE
OUR PATHS WOULD HAVE CROSSED. AT
OUR CORE VALENTINO WAS TALENTED
KIND HEARTED AND A DREAMER WITH
A SMILE SHE ALWAYS. SHE WAS
ALWAYS HELPING OTHERS WHILE
DREAMING OF BIGGER AND BETTER
WAYS SHE COULD IMPACT OTHERS.
SHE WAS FULL OF HOPES AND DREAMS
THAT INCLUDED GETTING A JOB AS
SOON AS SHE WAS ELIGIBLE TO SAVE
UP FOR AND ATTENDED SANTA MONICA
COLLEGE. SO THAT ONE DAY SHE
COULD OPEN UP A FOUNDATION FOR
THOSE THAT NEEDED HELP THE MOST
OR BECOME AN ENGINEER TO DESIGN
ROBOTS THAT CAN MAKE THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE- INNOCENCE SELFLESS
NATURE AND BEAUTIFUL SPIRIT
REPRESENT. WHAT IS SO SPECIAL
ABOUT OUR YOUTH. AND IT'S AN
ABSOLUTE TRAGEDY THAT SHE WAS
TAKEN SO YOUNG. VALENTINA IS
SURVIVED BY A LOVING FAMILY WHO
WILL ALWAYS REMEMBER HER AS AN
EXCELLENT DAUGHTER SISTER.
COUSIN NIECE AND GRANDDAUGHTER.
MISTER SPEAKER I'D LIKE TO ALSO
ADD SOMETHING TO THIS IDEA I
READ THIS STATEMENT BECAUSE A
WEEK AGO. I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CALL AND SPEAK WITH
VALENTINA'S PARENTS WHICH IS A
CALL THAT. NONE OF US REALLY
WANT TO EVER MAKE. WHAT WAS
STRIKING ABOUT MY CONVERSATION
WITH HER IS THAT. I WELL
UNDERSTAND THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF
THIS FAMILY. MY PARENTS AND I
IMMIGRATED HERE LEAVING THE WAR
TORN COUNTRY. HER PARENTS LEFT
THE COUNTRY BECAUSE OF LIMITED
OPPORTUNITY AND WANTED TO BRING
THEIR BOTH OF THEIR DAUGHTERS
HERE SO THAT THEY WOULD EXCEL.
GIVEN THEIR TALENTS AND
ABILITIES AND HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEEK THE EXCEL.
SHE WAS HERE FOR A VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME AND UNFORTUNATELY
DIDN'T EVEN GET AN OPPORTUNITY.
EXCEL. THAT IN ITSELF. IS ONE
PART OF THE STORY YET THE OTHER
IS AS A PARENT MYSELF OF THREE
CHILDREN WHEN I GO OVER EVERY
SINGLE FIBER OF THEIR HAIR. I
CAN JUST NLY IMAGINE I DON'T
EVEN WANT TO IMAGINE WHAT IT'S
LIKE. TO GO THROUGH ALL OF THESE
CHALLENGES TO MAKE THE
SACRIFICES TO MAKE SURE THAT.
YOU LEAVE YOUR COMFORT ZONE IN
THE COUNTRY YOUR AND IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE A BETTER OPPORTUNITY FOR
YOUR CHILDREN. EMIGRATE COME
INTO A NEW PLACE WHERE YOU NEED
TO LEARN AND REHASH EVERYTHING
ALL OVER AGAIN AND REBUILD JUST
TO GIVE AN OPPORTUNITY. FOR YOUR
CHILDREN AND THEN FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN. SO IT IT'S THIS IS THIS
THIS. TRAGIC SITUATION HAS
STRUCK ME UP PERSONALLY VERY
MUCH AND I NEEDED TO EXPRESS
THAT. PARENTS AND- I ASKED THEM
WHAT THEY WOULD WANT ME TO
EXPRESS ON HER BEHALF AND SO THE
NOTES THAT I READ. UP MOST OF
THEM WERE NOTES FROM THEM AND
FROM THEIR HEARTS SO ON BEHALF
OF ALL OF YOU ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES ALSO EXTENDED TO
THEM- OUR CONDOLENCES ON BEHALF
OF THE INSTITUTION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN.
THREE OF US HONESTLY GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS- I RISE TODAY TO JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND ZARIA- TO
ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF VALENTIN
OUT A YEAH NOT THAT I THOUGHT
WHOSE LIFE WAS TRAGICALLY TAKEN
UP IN NORTH HOLLYWOOD IN MY
DISTRICT TWO DAYS BEFORE
CHRISTMAS I VALENTINO WAS BORN
ON MAY TWENTY SIX TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN AND GREW UP IN MY SCHOOL A
WORKING CLASS NEIGHBORHOOD IN
SANTIAGO CHILE. SHE IMMIGRATED
TO THE UNITED STATES WITH HER
MOTHER ABOUT SIX MONTHS AGO TO
REUNITE WITH HER OLDER SISTER IN
LOS ANGELES WHOM SHE MISSED
DEARLY WHILE THEY WERE A PART.
IN THE SHORT TIME HERE IN THE U.
S. VALENTINA QUICKLY FELT THE
PROMISE OF A NEW START. OF HER
AND EVEN SAID THAT HER MOST
IMPORTANT DREAM WAS TO BECOME AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN. VALENTINA HAD
SO MANY DREAMS FOR HER FUTURE
SHE DREAMED OF BECOMING AN
ENGINEER SHE WANTED TO DESIGN
ROBOTS TO HELP MAKE THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE AND- AS A LITTLE
GIRL THAT WAS MY DREAM I WANTED
TO BE AN ENGINEER I BECAME AN
ENGINEER- AND IT WAS. IT WAS
HEARTBREAKING TO SEE A YOUNG
GIRL- THAT IS NOT ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT DREAM. MULLIN
DENIES SURVIVED BY HER MOTHER
SOLEDAD BUT OUT THAT HER FATHER
FROM PABLO OR DEANNA LET AND
THAT'S- HER GRANDMOTHER AND HER
OLDER SISTER. NO FAMILY DESERVES
TO LIVE THROUGH THIS PAIN AND I
OFFER MY DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO
VALENTINA'S FAMILY AS THEY
GRAPPLE THROUGH THE LOSS OF
THEIR CHILD. I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF ALLEN
DENIES MEMORY AND KEEP HER
FAMILY. IN OUR THOUGHTS DURING
THIS INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS RIVAS MS
POWER QUE HAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
COLLEAGUES I ASKED US TO JOIN
TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF ONE OF
THE GREATS COACH JOHN MADDEN.
JOHN MADDEN WAS ONE OF THE
GREATEST LEGENDS OF FOOTBALL
FROM HIS CAREER COACHING THE
OAKLAND RAIDERS TO HIS SIGNATURE
COMMENTARY AND THE VIDEO GAME
THAT PLAYS OUT THE SPORT HE
LOVED. JOHN MADDEN WASN'T JUST A
LIFELONG FOOTBALL THE BOOTY HE
WAS ALSO A LIFELONG CALIFORNIA.
HE GREW UP IN DALY CITY IN THE
NINETEENTH DISTRICT PLAYING
FOOTBALL FROM A YOUNG AGE. HE
ONLY LASTED A YEAR IN PORTLAND
FOR COLLEGE COMING BACK TO
RETURN TO CAL POLY'S FAMILIES
OBISPO AND HIS HOME STATE. WHERE
HE MET HIS WIFE VIRGINIA AND
EARNED HIS TEACHING CREDENTIAL
AND MASTERS DEGREE. ALL WHILE
PLAYING AS AN OFFENSIVE LINEMAN
THE ENTIRE TIME. MATT IN CHANGED
THE GAME. AFTER BEING DRAFTED BY
THE PHILADELPHIA EAGLES IN
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT HE SUFFERED
A CAREER ENDING INJURY IN HIS
FIRST TRAINING CAMP. NOT WANT TO
WALLOW HE MADE COACHING HIS
LIFELONG STUDY. IF IT STUDIOUSLY
WATCH RECORDINGS OF HIS TEAM AND
INTERVIEWED PLAYERS. HE SAW LIKE
NO ONE ELSE AND COMMUNICATED THE
DELICATE DANCE OF A COMPLICATED
SPORT. AT AGE THIRTY TWO HE
BECAME THE YOUNGEST NFL HEAD
COACH WITH THE RAIDERS AND
DEDICATED HIMSELF TO THE TEAM
AND BRINGING THEM THEIR FIRST
SUPER BOWL TITLE IN FIFTEEN
YEARS OF INNOVATIVE COACHING
WOULD HAVE BEEN QUITE ENOUGH OF
A CAREER. BUT IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE UPON HIS RETIREMENT
FOR THE RAIDERS HE BUILT THE
SECOND LEGACY OF FOOTBALL
COMMENTARY. LIKE MANY OF YOU I
GREW UP WITH JOHN MADDEN IN MY
HOME EVERY WEEK. IN THE BOOTH HE
HAD HIS OWN TRADEMARK STYLE. AND
AMERICA LOVED HIM FOR IT HIS
ICONIC BOOM REPEATED AND CALLED
OUT BY FANS FOR DECADES. IT
BECAME A HOLIDAY TRADITION TO
SEE MADDEN BROADCASTING GAMES ON
THANKSGIVING. CELEBRATING WITH
THE WINNING TEAM NEXT TO HIS
BOSS THE MADDEN CRUISER WELL
THEY ALL ENJOYED A TRADUCTION.
WHICH SHE HELPED POPULARIZE.
MATANCERA OPPORTUNITIES
EVERYWHERE STARRING AN ICONIC
COMMERCIAL CAMPAIGNS MOVIES
RADIO GIGS IN ANTICIPATING THE
RISE OF ELECTRONIC MEDIA WITH
THIS PARTNERSHIP TO CREATE THE
FOOTBALL VIDEO GAME THE BEARS
HIS NAME. IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
COACH MADDEN WAS FINALLY
IMMORTALISED IN BRONZE AND WAS
INDUCTED INTO THE PRO FOOTBALL
HALL OF FAME IN CANTON OHIO. OUT
SIDE FOOTBALL COACH MATT IN
DEDICATED HIS HAND QUESTIONABLE
SPIRIT TO HIS FAMILY AND TO THE
COMMUNITY I GET TO REPRESENT
DISTRICT SIXTEEN. MORE THAN
ANYTHING COACH MAN WAS TO A
DEVOTED HUSBAND FATHER AND
GRANDFATHER TO HIS WIFE VIRGINIA
AND SONS JOE AND MIKE AND HIS
GRANDCHILDREN. HE RAISED HIS
FAMILY IN PLEASANTON AND HE AND
HIS FAMILY HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS ON THE TRI VALLEY.
AROUNDPLEASANTON COACH BROWN
WITH SIMPLY JOHN. WOULD OFTEN
SPOT HIM AT THE RANCHO GRANTED
TALK URREA- OVER AT ANOTHER
LOCAL SPOT VIC'S ALL STAR
KITCHEN. MACINNES SONS HAVE BEEN
KEY PLAYERS ON THE LOCAL ART
SCENE AND INVESTED DEEPLY IN THE
REDEVELOPMENT OF PLEASANTON AND
LIVERMORE. THEY PLAYED A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN THE
REVITALIZATION OF LIVERMORE
DOWNTOWN. AND OVER IN PLEASANTON
THEY BUILT THE ROADS HOTEL
UPGRADED DOWNTOWN BUILDINGS TO
BRING NEW BUSINESS AND CHAMPION
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FACILITY FOR SENIORS.
JOHN PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY
FOURTH AT EIGHTY FIVE YEARS OLD.
HE LIVES ON IN SO MANY WAYS
THROUGH THE MANY INCREDIBLE
LIVES HE LIVED. THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE MEMORIES COACH AND FOR
ALL THE YOU HAVE DONE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO BE JOINED IN
THE MEMORY OF JOHN MADDEN AND
ALL THAT HE BROUGHT TO THE SPORT
OF FOOTBALL INTO CALIFORNIA MAY
HIS MEMORY BE A BLESSING. FAKER
IS BACKING HIM. MISTER GIBSON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO **** BODY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF DOORS
TAAPSEE OVERT OF LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA SHE WAS KNOWN BY MANY
. SHE WAS KNOWN BY MANY NAMES
INCLUDING COUNCILWOMAN.
COMMISSION PRESIDENT WOMAN OF
THE YEAR SHE BROKE POLITICAL
BARRIERS. BUT HER INFLUENCE HER
FEARLESS EXAMPLE OF MENTOR SHIP
MADE SO MANY. CALL HER MOTHER
DORIS MOTHER DOORS WAS BURKE WAS
BORN IN VICKSBURG. MISSISSIPPI
IN NINETEEN THIRTY ONE HER
FAMILY MOVED TO LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN FORTY TWO
. WHERE SHE ATTENDED ST
ANTHONY'S ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND
HIGH SCHOOL AND IN NINETEEN
FORTY NINE MOTHER DOORS BECAME
THE FIRST. BLACK STUDENTS TO
GRADUATE FROM ST ANTHONY'S HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE.
ST ANTHONY'S INDUCTED HER INTO
THEIR HALL OF FAME SHE COMPLETED
HER UNDERGRAD AND GRADUATE
EDUCATION ALONG THE WAY BECAME A
DISTINGUISHED PUBLIC SERVICE.
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PROBATION OFFICE WHERE SHE
SERVED NINETEEN YEARS AFTER
SERVING ON MULTIPLE BOARDS SHE
BECAME THE FIRST BLACK WOMAN
ELECTED TO THE LONG BEACH CITY
COUNCIL IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO.
SHE ALSO SERVED AS VICE CHAIR
TWICE IN THAT TERM. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE SHE WAS THE
FIRST BLACK PERSON AND ONLY THE
THIRD WOMAN TO SERVE ON THE LONG
BEACH BOARD OF HARBOR COMMISSION
SHE ALSO SERVED AS THE
COMMISSION PRESIDENT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE. SHE CHANGED
LIVES AND BROKE BARRIERS
WHEREVER SHE WENT. IN THE ROLE
IN HER ROLE SHE UP LIFTED
ADVOCATED IN WAYS THAT BENEFIT
ALL PEOPLE ESPECIALLY BLACK
PEOPLE EXPRESSLY MYSELF. SHE'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR SO MANY OF THE
PLACES I'VE BEEN ABLE TO SEE AND
WITNESS YES BECAUSE SHE WAS A
TIRELESS AND FEARLESS LEADER.
MEMBERS MANY OF YOU KNOW ABOUT
THE STORY ABOUT THE DASH. IS THE
DATE THAT YOU WERE BORN AND ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE DASH THE
DATE THAT YOU PASS WELL SHE
LIVED HER DASH TO THE FULLEST
AND TOUCHED SO MANY LIVES. THANK
YOU MOTHER DOORS FOR CHANGING SO
MANY LIVES AND HEARTS IN OUR
CITIES AND ALSO IN THIS STATE.
LONG BEACH HAS LOST A LEGACY.
THE WORLD HAS LOST A PUBLIC
SERVANT. THANK YOU MOTHER DOORS
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MOTHER
DOORS. THANK IMAGE GIVE SENATE
MISTER DONNELLY WERE ALSO
RECOGNIZED ON THIS GERMAN IN
MEMORY. MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
TO RISE TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF
DORIS TOPSY OVERS SHE WAS A FINE
LADY. SHE ALWAYS HAD A GOOD TIME
WITH PEOPLE SHE WILL BE MISSED.
DOORS MOVED TO LONG BEACH FROM
VICKSBURG MISSISSIPPI AS AN
ELEVEN YEAR OLD IN NINETEEN
FORTY TWO. WHERE SHE LATER
INTEGRATION CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY LONG BEACH AND
CHAPMAN UNIVERSITY. SHE BEGAN
HER CAREER IN PUBLIC SERVICE AS
A CALIFORNIA YOUTH AUTHORITY
COUNSELOR AND LATER SERVED AS A
PROBATION OFFICER FOR THE
COUNTY. OF LOS ANGELES ALTHOUGH
YOU WOULD NEVER HAVE KNOWN IT
MEETING HER. AFTER RETIRING
DORIS WAS APPOINTED TO THIS IT
TO THE CITY OF LONG BEACH'S
CIVIL SERVICE COMMAND. A
COMMISSION SERVING THE ONE TERM
AS PRESIDENT AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED. IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO DOORS BECAME THE FIRST BLACK
COUNCILMAN FOR THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH REPRESENTING THE SIXTH
DISTRICT. ALL AWFUL ALSO SERVING
AS VICE MAYOR TWICE. DORIS IS
SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND RALPH.
THREE SONS AND HER GRANDCHILDREN
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE MANY OTHERS
WHO REFERRED TO HER AS MOTHER.
MOTHER DORIS IS LEGACY TO
IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR OUR COMMUNITY MY COMMUNITY
WILL FOREVER LIVE ON AND I'M
THANKFUL TO HAVE KNOWN TO HAVE
KNOWN HER SHE COULD LAUGH SHE
COULD DANCE AND SHE LOVES PEOPLE
AND YOU KNEW IT. I ASKED TO THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED THE MEMORY OF
FORMER COUNCILMAN DORIS TOPSY
OVER. THANK YOU MISTER THOMAS.
MR LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. WELL OUR
JOURNALISM MEMBER ALWAYS A
SOLEMN OCCASION. I'VE NEVER
HEARD IN THE MEMORY. OF AN
ENTIRE MASTERED FAMILY. I
PRESIDENT BUT NONE OF US WILL
EVER HAVE TO DO THIS AGAIN.
ARRESTER JOURNAL MEMORY OF
RETIRED CORRECTIONAL OFFICER.
FIFTY ONE YEAR OLD ERICA
ENGLAND. UNDER FOUR GRAND
CHILDREN. ELEVEN YEAR OLD
NEUMEYER SEVEN YEAR OLD GJ.
THROUGH YOUR LOCATING. AND ONE
YEAR OLD NOR BROWN. THEY WERE
TAKEN FROM US. MUCH TOO SOON
UNDER TRAGIC AND HEARTBREAKING
CIRCUMSTANCE. WHEN WE CONFRONT
SAYS MOST VIOLENCE A TRAUMATIZED
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY. THE HILL
WE MUST JOIN ONE ANOTHER DEEP
REFLECTIONOF THE TRUE VALUE OF
LIFE. LET US NOW BRIEFLY FOCUS
ON THE PERSONAL HISTORY THE MADE
ERICA. EXCEPTIONAL AND A
PREVIOUS APPRECIATE. BUT SHE HAD
WHAT PROPELS MANY OF US TO BE
HERE TODAY A SERVANT'S HEART.
ERICA STARTED HER LIFE OF
SERVICE VERY YOUNG. SHE JOINED
THE LAPD EXPLORER PROGRAM.
MARINE JROTC PROGRAM AS WELL AS
A KID CALIFORNIA CADET CORPS. A
NATIONAL GUARD PROGRAM. IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN SHE BEGAN
HER CAREER WITH CDCR AND WORKED
AS A CORRECTIONAL OFFICER AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY UNTIL HER
UNTIMELY DEATH. WHEN SHE WAS
FREE FROM WORK SHE ENJOYED
SPENDING TIME AND PLAYING WITH
THEIR GRANDCHILDREN. AND SERVED
AS DEACON S. AT THE NEW
TESTAMENT WORSHIP CHURCH. SHE IS
SURVIVED BY FIVE CHILDREN AND
SOON TO BE TWO GROWN CHILDREN. I
ASKED WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF. OFFICER ERICA ENGLAND. UNDER
GRANDCHILDREN. NEUMEIER G. J.
KADIAN THE NOR BROWN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MITCHELL I CAN
MEMBERS PLEASE READ THE NAME TO
THE DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS TO RETURN A
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED. IN THE JOURNAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE COMMITTEE ON
BANKING AND FINANCE WILL MEET
TODAY AT. TWO THIRTY PM. IN ROOM
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN- THE COMMITTEE
ON NATURAL RESOURCES WILL BE
TODAY AT. TWO THIRTY PM IN ROOM. FOR FORTY FOUR. THE COMMITTEE
ON REVENUE AND TAXATION WILL BE
TODAY AT TWO THIRTY IN ROOM. ONE
TWENTY SIX. TODAY'S
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. YEAH
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION HAS
BEEN POSTPONED HOWEVER THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION BILL
HEARING IS TODAY AT THREE THIRTY
PM IN ROOM FORTY TWO- TO
SESSIONS SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY JANUARY ELEVENTH CHECK
IN SESSION WEDNESDAY JANUARY
TWELFTH. CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY JANUARY THIRTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION FRIDAY JANUARY
THE FOURTEENTH FLOOR SESSION IS
AT NINE AM. ALL OF THE ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUE
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. MISTER
GIBSON MOVES AND MR LACKEY
SECONDSTHAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL FRIDAY JANUARY
FOURTEENTH. AT NINE AM WE ARE JR.